[Music]
Ah ah ah
uh
ni My name
is Yamada from Grastroke. The
Japanese food itself is a female
and I'm telling you as a 10-organizer.  It is a commentary that when
you eat this,
you will know where and where it will be effective if
you have a body
and you will not know it in history, so it is explained that it is naturally put out.
Analysis is especially the best.  It's a sense of the seasons that you use, isn't it? In
Japan, there is this snow breeze in May, and
that iris flower is likened to a sword.  There is a Hooper's custom of paying that
.
Bamboo that came out there with a sword slap, you're stopping the soy sauce of the lamp type.
Unagi Hane Today, I entered that hospital Nagi from that Japan
.
In that room, it's called a sushi banquet
. I see it too much. 6 Matsumi
I'm carrying a runner on my back
. The scent of cedar.
The purpose of doing that is in
that analysis. Various things.
I call it analysis. I'm trying various things.
However, if
you go through everything, the story is really connected like this.
That's where I am. There is
something that increases from the soul of my heart, so
I want to continue to see that enough is a function.
[Music]